okay we're down okay so why are we
losing his mask is the ultimate shame a
luchador can feel I can't steal it back
I need to earn it I mean how do we do
that we heard a lot of people get you so
what are we doing guys we tear this
place apart my mask
guess I'll take your word for it
yes
DeMeo
we're attacking it
interrogate the manager how we got here
why didn't you get your mask back sooner
he broke my spirit I didn't think I was
worthy enough to get it back well made
you feel worthy again meeting the Saints
okay here yes this isn't a knockout
Frank I know every curve every color
every mark on this mask put it on and
let's get out of here
you got it yeah oh my god angel de la
muerte is reborn okay we really need to
leave now
not yet it's time to send kill being a
message it's like that you crazy I can't
do this
that's his slash Jason
[ __ ] sorry so there's one down there
I'll get this one
Oh quick I can't get
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
yeah that's good [ __ ] fat [ __ ]
as I
[ __ ] army
that I could use a massage it's a guy
like Heidi and get him flowers upstairs
it cleared upstairs I guess [ __ ]
I can't get good its laughs thank a good
tips out for Harambee